ouais
[Musique]
tandis de l'orgue qui vais le roi des
instruments depuis maintenant 19 ans
celui de coignières est au centre des
dimanches musicaux les concerts
reprennent le 2 octobre à 17 heures avec
le trio à coup la flûte traversière
saxophone et mais org
c'est un trio qui vient du sud de la
france
deslandes et qui propose de faire un
petit parcours musical à travers les
compositeurs du la fin du 19e siècle
arrivé à l'église saint germain
d'auxerre en 1993 grâce à du mécénat
l'instrument fait aujourd'hui partie du
patrimoine connaît rien
quand la musique du xviiie siècle au
xxème et xxième siècle
sera présente mais nous avons associé
sur certains concernent des instruments
qui seront pas du tout courant et qui
permettent de d'écouter autre chose que
des instruments à cordes avec avec
l'orgueil orgue de cristal ou encore
hommage aux femmes compositeur quatre
autres rendez vous sont proposés tout au
long de la saison
l'instrument roi attend son public